stories of torture and family members
going missing or being found dead have
become increasingly common in Bangladesh
nearly decade has passed but Salma Islam
still breaks down when she describes the
moment she saw her husband's body he
belonged to the opposition Bangladesh
nationalist
party in 2014 Just 3 days after my
husband's arrest by plain clothed police
we found his body with multiple bullet
marks and torture signs near our village
home the family still faces frequent
harassment and intimidation from the
authorities are we not citizens of this
country with legitimate rights she
asked at the beginning of this month one
of my three brothers was picked up by
plain clothed detectives and was missing
for 6 days before he appeared in court
with signs of torture on his body he
could barely stand up later he was sent
to jail another of my brothers is on the
Run political analysts said there's
barely any space left in prisons
thousands of opposition members have
been rounded up across the country in
the past 2 weeks many even don't belong
to any political parties the central
office of the main opposition party has
been CAU up by police and is considered
a crime scene the city remains TS and
traffic is significantly low in the past
week dozens of vehicles have been
torched and damaged during what the
opposition called a general strike and
blockade the government blames the party
for the vandalism and encourages
supporters to form vigilante groups
operating under police
protection they were given the order to
deal with the culprits who were
vandalizing and starting fires instead
they ended up arresting many innocent
people under no circumstances should
this happen critics said the
government's promise to ensure a
conducive environment for free and fair
elections in January contradicts the
reality on the ground K Chri Al jazer
Daka make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer